Can you tell me a little
about your role at LogicBox?
>> So I'm a Chief Application Architect.
And what this means is that I oversee
all of our app development and
pretty central in coming up
with the initial design for
any kind of new products
that we develop.
I often do a fair amount of prototyping,
data modeling,
early in a new product that we're
developing for a new client.
I'll sometimes, often actually,
interact with customers
to make sure we're clear on
requirements when we start.
And I'll often make a lot of
the initial programing decisions and
then start to farm it out
to a group of developers.
>> And I'm guessing you also
have a strategic role as far as
how a company is going to be
developing applications on into
the future
>> That's right.
So, in addition to
Chief Application Architect I'm also
Executive Vice President.
>> So, as an architect,
what kinds of decisions
do you have to deal with in terms
of structuring this code base.
>> So typically, there are kind of
two scenarios where I get involved.
So there are new configurations of
existing services that we've implemented
before and there most of my
work is just in requirements
analysis to understand
differences between clients.
And helping to put together
an application development team to go
extend that configuration
to the new client.
That's kind of the normal
development role, and I do that for
several products in our family
that we've done many times before.
We've deployed these services many
times before for previous clients and
it's really just a matter of kind of
bringing up a team of developers and
just showing them what the architecture
is and telling them how to flesh it out.
For new products, and
as of not too long ago,
the forecast manager that we're going to
talk about later was a new product.
For that, I actually had to do a lot
of the initial development of it,
and we did things like
initial scalability analysis.
There's often some pretty complex
calculations that need to be performed.
Under not under real-time, but
under time constraints that a user
would need to deem acceptable.
So I do a lot of initial
scalability analysis,
which involves coding up
some solution approaches.
Making sure that we understand how to
do the integration with all the various
data that come from the customer and
also just doing data modeling.
Because, a lot of the times we
find when we do a new application,
there's a significant data modeling
exercise that needs to get done
before we can really
start making progress.
>> And how about the software process
itself, the development activities in
particularly, strategically, as far as
improving productivity in the long run.
>> Yeah, I also play a role
in that as you might imagine.
We use, we're an agile shop,
and so we tend to like
really short iterations where we have
demos at the end of those iterations.
We use your traditional Jeera and
other kinds of technologies for
issue tracking.
But yeah, our process mainly is
one of when we have a new project,
do an initial architectural
assessment which may take a month or
two, to do the kind of prototyping and
scalability analysis that we need.
And then we proceed when we
start bringing developers on,
usually with a small number of
developers it scales up over time.
Rather than with a big group
that starts at the beginning.
And we use a very iterative usually
one to two week cycle iterations.
So this is a grunt process.